Okay.
So, here we have two frames.
On the left we have the original model
the, the model is sort of a time and,
and we're going to call that zero.
And on the right we have some candidate.
Something, some place in
terms of how its changed and
this can be centered at some value y,
some pixel y.
So on the left,
we have our initial distribution.
Okay.
So this was our
histogram that we computed, in our area,
and it's typically called q.
And q's got a set of bins, u1 through m.
And because it's going to
represent a density,
we enforce the fact that
sum of them equals one.
So how do we do that?
Well we just sum them all up and
we divide all the bins by that value.
Okay.
And
you see we have the audaciousness
to call it probability.
Okay?
Because
well were going to take these samples
and we're going to assume that it's
representative of a probability
distribution function.
So that's our distribution at
the initial of the target.
At some new location.
Okay.
We can compute the distribution again.
So now p of u is a function of y where
y is the point that we're considering.
Remember you have to consider
p of z given the state.
So y is going to be that,
that new point.
And it's called y instead of x,
that's how it's done in the Mean-Shift
Literature if you read this, this is,
this is what you would see.
And again,
were going to build a distribution
by assuming that these
things sum up to one.
So we have this two distributions and
what we have to do is we need
a similarity function that compares
them, that compares the original
q and the new p of y which is
the density at this proposed place.
So the question is how are we
going to compare these distributions?
Now there are a variety of functions
that you can use to compare histograms,
where the histograms, are,
are normalized to one, so
they represent probabilities.
There's the min value.
There's, there's chi-squared,
a variety of them.
The one that was used with respect to
Mean-Shift tracking is referred to
as the Bhattacharyya Coefficient.
Bhattacharyya Coefficient comes
from something related to
the Bhattacharyya distance.
It's simply a way of
comparing distributions.
What you do is,
you take your distributions here, and
you change it by taking the square
root of each of the components.
So, if q is a distribution,
q1 through qm, then
q prime is going to be the square root
of q1 through the square root of qm.
Same thing with the new proposed
distribution, p, around y.
We're going to take p prime,
where we take the square roots.
When we define it that way,
the Bhattacharyya relationship
is defined as follows.
Okay?
Just take the sum over the product
of those square roots.
Okay.
Well you might ask,
why would you do that.
>> Why would you do that?
>> Well you quickly realize that
if you take the magnitude of
those square rooted vectors.
Right?
The magnitude is the square
root of the sum of the squares.
Well, the sum of the squares is what?
Well, since the sum of the qs is one,
the sum of the square roots
then squared is going to be one,
so the magnitude is one.
So, these magnitudes here, those are
one, so that means you just have this.
So basically you're
computing the dot product,
the cosine of the angle between
the square roots of those distributions.
And that sum of the square root,
the thing in the box here,
that's what's referred to as
the Bhattacharyya Coefficient.
It's just a way of comparing
distributions, and so
that's what they did.